[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip aujourd'hui je
reçois l'artiste plasticienne frédéric
petit dans un écran fantastique à savoir
le potager du roi à versailles alors
frédéric petit donc déjà merci de nous
accorder du temps dans cette journée si
particulière parce que vous êtes en
train d'installer les sculptures que
vous proposez donc au public pour cette
période estivale alors on va essayer de
vous connaître un petit peu mieux vous
avez une une carrière très riche très
variées vous avez utilisé différents
matériaux explorer différents univers
bref là on va se concentrer un peu sur
l'essentiel est d'abord vos débuts le
tissage ou ça vous intéressait déjà
personnellement et puis en 71 il s'est
passé un déclic oui en fait j'ai
découvert le tissage
presque d'une manière comment dire
incongru on pourrait bien parce que
j'étais avec une amie en vacances qui
avait des files moi j'en avais trouvé
aussi aux opus je bricolais toujours un
petit peu quand même mais elle elle
avait une notion quand même du tissage
et d'eau qu'on a on s'est prise de
passion pour ça parce qu' on
cherche en commentant les fils on a
ramassé des cageots d'orange et on
attend d'une fusion des cageots d'orange
et on s'est rendu compte que c'était
parfait pour jacques les voilà
propre métier bas sauf que évidemment
très vite c'était insuffisant et donc
effectivement c'est en explorant un peu
à l'époque on parlait pas beaucoup de
tout ça de tissage artisanal
donc c'est par hasard en allant au musée
de l'homme que j'ai vu des métiers
primitif et que j'ai compris le système
de dennis pour écarter les fils de
chênes enfin voilà ça c'était ses
protégés ni de les actualiser partie de
la technique bien que après j'ai
continué d'une manière très pareil
toujours très primitive de faire des
images que j'appelais c'était des
tapisseries des petites images
miniatures mais toujours sur des métiers
tout simple à clous mais quand même avec
toujours ce système qui m'avait changer
la vie de nice pour un quartier défile
voilà ce qu'on prend oui vous êtes une
artiste plasticienne bien sûr mais
jamais je voulais le dire thaler et puis
j'ai oublié l'artiste du fil un peu
constamment sur le fil c'est un lien qui
est que l'on retrouve tout au long de
votre pause et un lien vraiment constant
effectivement le fils d'un field fil
textile dont on n'est pas au bout de
plus de vingt ans
comme on dit on m'a donné envie quand
même d'aller voir explorer plus loin
parce que ça ça me contraignait à la
surface plane et j'avais envie de
d'explorer le volume et donc j'ai c'est
là que j'ai avec le fil de fer j'ai
commencé à faire des choses en volume et
du fil de fer du petit fils tente alors
il faut dire qu'on était toujours dans
le fil voilà du tissage vous êtes passé
à la broderie oui vous avez même fait
deux séjours en chine pour apprendre le
point de l'âme la bretagne au fil de
soins oui déjà les techniques j'imagine
thématique lien et vous et vos oeuvres
sont des miniatures ou une finesse
d'être des miniatures ou des miniatures
hallucinant il était déjà prêt on m'a
plus grand mais en local images elles
mêmes
et on peut envoyer ses oeuvres à
proposera de l'actualité mais ces
oeuvres laïques sont quand même très
important de nos dons et à votre
carrière est ce que c'est une sorte de
ligne d'horizon
réinventer oui en fait faut dire que je
les appelais les premières pièces que
j'ai fait je les appelais hobereau
chinoise parce que c'était réellement
pour moi le symbole de ce voyage que
j'avais fait de l'orient à l'occident
donc le fromage le voyageur vous avez
faim encore
dans le temps parce qu'il ya aussi le
temps de la réalisation et qui symbolise
aussi à peu
sur un temps plus long le chemin chemin
de la vie shmona vicois voilà notre
soutien tout ça d'une manière
inconsciente d'accord ok alors
maintenant revenons à nos moutons qui
sont des cocons alors vous nous proposez
trois cultures différentes mais de ceux
qui sont après en série chacune mais
alors les cocons oui les nids et les
luttes oui alors quel est votre
matériaux donc faussée sculpture là
alors
en majeure partie du fer à béton et donc
quand j'ai voulu fil de soie au veto du
fil de fer en fer à béton puisque en
fait le départ le point de départ
c'était mes petits nids qui rime donc
qui faisait le lien avec quand même le
fils de cause de soin de soi voilà donc
ça qui m'a permis aussi de continuer
d'explorer toutes ces toutes les
bannières de triturer le files d'attenté
dans mes longs et de louise et de notre
l'essai de l'autre la cie voilà et
et après cette envie qui était bien
réaliser parce que je sais cette série
est très satisfaisante mais j'avais
quand même envie de d'un seul coup de du
coup de passer à une échelle quand ce
que j'avais toujours travaillé en
miniature a été une grande tentation est
donc je vois là je me suis je me suis
carrément non c'est parce que c'était
quand même une sacrée entreprise et de
travailler le fer à béton s'enraya à
reconnaître de rien savoir soudé tout ça
donc de l'aiguillé je sais pas c'est
quoi vos besoins et d'épicés pas grand
chose c'est facile je souhaiterais balle
mais c'est je suis d'accord mais
suffisamment et voilà suffisamment pour
que ça tienne et est donc donc j'ai
réalisé ces petites niches les ai
réalisées en très très grand et le plus
grand possible alors un grand effet
quelle taille quand on sait pas si quand
il fait à mettre 10 de dia même à mehdi
dans l'omelette octroyé le droit d'
d'abord des insurgés en mai c'était
aussi effectivement le besoin d'affirmer
que moi aussi je pouvais faire ça voilà
c'est vrai que quand on fait des du
textile est toujours miniature on est
traître est cantonné très camp des oui
c'est ensemble qu'on nous dit d'ailleurs
il part voilà kharkov méthane
et pour prouver que en tant qu'artiste
artiste libre indépendante je
choisissais de
dessiner avec mon fils de fer des
oeuvres de création pure et avec avec le
fils mais que justement
j'étais capable aussi de passer au
volume et de faire des grandes choses et
quand les choses voilà et c'est ce qu'on
va pouvoir admirer donc cet effet alors
on revient aux cons oui le cocon le nid
la hutte qui aussi sorte d'abris pour
les épaules et ce avant l'aller puis à
c'est une manière de protéger les
pierres les pièces et une passion c'est
quelque chose que j'ai que je que je
donc que commentaires qui me qui me
faisait rien si ma ouhlala merci
depuis depuis tout petit comme beaucoup
d'enfants mais que j'ai gardé je
ramassais pierre je cherche dans maman
ma cour je cherche les petits trésors
dans ma cour n'est toujours pas retombée
au plus juste des petits fossiles minus
que je trouve des pierres percées que je
gardais tout petit caillou percée que je
fais je fais des colliers avec big n
voilà ça va de sao pierre plus plus
importante dans les petites pierres
rondes que je trouve dans les bois ou
sombrent dans un champ pas très loin de
chez moi et appartement j'ai trouvé ces
pierres qui me font rêver à tout à fait
j'ai eu envie de leur donner un abri et
donc les heatles et de les élever
d'accord et alors ces cocons ceni et
peut pas s'empêcher de penser à la
notion de d'éclosion de naissance des
deux lieux d'évolution avec la hutte
peut-être aussi que c'est un la hauteur
des billets ici de valognes un lien
entre la terre et le ciel aussi d'accord
qui est justement qui se rattache avec
qui
on peut de référence à une série que
j'ai fait aussi qu'ils étaient des
sphères que je su sport des destins qui
sont en fait comme des dénis fermé donc
des comme des cocos aussi dans lesquels
jean ferme des pierres donc et mais que
je suspends donc c'est une forme de
cosmos qu'à coller tout ça c'est ça
pourrait être un peu phase si on peut
dire entre guillemets mais ça ne l'est
pas c'est inconsciemment c'est mon
rattachement moi un petit choses
minuscules mais qui a sa place ici sur
terre et qui cherche le mieux possible à
magnifier toute cette beauté en créant
en créant et alors justement pour
revenir une façon un peu plus concrète
quand on fait une installation qu'est ce
qu'on se dit elles ont choisi l'endroit
on se dit que l homme est un jeu
formidable on
voit un espace soit fermées soit ouvert
comme un jardin ici et on
dit ça c'est comme si c'était ma maison
je vais installer ma maison à d'accord
et là c'est réellement comme ça que ça
se passe je m'installe dans ma maison
alors là ce qui s'est passé par exemple
on a fait on a fait un repérage on était
plusieurs à regarder c'est très
impressionnant c'est ce jardin oui c'est
tellement grand c'est tellement grand
retrouvez le en fait j'ai fait des
photos qui après je suis restée toute
seule j'ai refait le même parcours j'ai
regardé et puis d'un seul coup il ya des
endroits qui étaient plus évident et je
me suis pas encore approprié mais qui
devenait quand même plus évident et
après la maison je me suis je n'ai pas
paniqué me dire on l'est sont reposés
vidéo et puis petit à petit basset
ddd lieu comme ça ils sont épaulés
émerger et qui se sont imposés et du
coup j'étais bah oui là là je suis chez
moi la rocaille jeunes dans leur cocon
vous allez tout mettre dans la rocaille
non ça c'est prévu pas du tout il ya
donc un espace ici déjà sûr il y aura
d'autres espaces je crois que c'est ils
appellent ça le carré potager ouais en
face du bassin savez quoi tout en
évolution aujourd'hui vous êtes en train
d'installer donc on ne voit pas à vous
demander de détails extrêmement rare et
partir à la recherche de deux heures
parce que c'est donc c'est pas compliqué
des cocons des nids géants et des huttes
voilà voilà alors frédéric petit un
grand merci nous avons encore du temps
gros merci pour vos belles oeuvres qui
vont un très bel écrin j'en suis sûr et
qu'on va pouvoir merci à voir tout cet
été
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis au
revoir à bientôt
[Musique]